the heat's not stopping slotzilla let's
check back in with rocky she's live at
fremont street's famous zipline ahead of
their eighth anniversary hi rocky how's
it going out there
hey jc and jillian is going great it is
hot and it is not stopping these people
these tourists where you guys from where
are you from
seattle we've got texas and then we also
have the uk here represented they are
taking off to enjoy the famous slotzilla
here on fremont street celebrating the
8th anniversary
and they're off how do you feel about
that paul it's a joy every single time
he's just smiling and people are just
having the out of the time of their life
i love it i love it so let's take a zip
line down memory lane if you will okay
so do you have any favorite memories in
within these eight years of being here
on fremont street i'll tell you it's
such a spectacle right we actually had
one time we had steve aoki the world
famous uh dj we had him fly on slotzilla
at the end of slotzilla uh there is a
stage main street stage so the next time
you see him he's literally uh doing his
dj thing in front of the largest crowd
in the history of fremont from casino
center to main street it was epic that
is epic and totally vegas we love that
anything else i know you guys did some
stuff with some sports teams too yeah so
uh year one of the vegas nights we
introduced the entire team to the city
of las vegas and so we would have their
mascot and uh some of their team members
fly on slotzilla next time you see them
they're on the red carpet you know
celebrating to the city of las vegas
that is amazing and you know i have to
ask this has been here for eight years
and it's only getting bigger and better
is there just one person you can think
of that you would want to ride flatville
anybody in the world i gotta tell you so
slot is is kind of a character unto
itself uh and there's some amazing
talents on the strip uh one comes to my
katy perry would be a great one her
personality is larger than life this is
the largest slot machine in the world so
katie our open invitation we'd love to
have you fly bring the camera back over
here bring the camera back over here
lance lance bring the camera back
we got we got to get him saying that to
katy perry go ahead
uh again if we had one person it would
be katy perry she's a larger-than-life
personality uh and so katie this is an
open invitation to you and your team and
we'd love to have you fly come down and
fly on us and now you'll have an
absolute ball oh my god that is so cool
you gotta ride the largest slot machine
in the world katy perry thanks to las
vegas now we gotta get that on there too
we gotta get that live yes okay we get
the exclusive all right let's talk
numbers we've got a couple riders going
out right now just give us the
statistics of what people are
experiencing when they get on yeah so
ultimately we do about anywhere between
1200 and 2000 riders every single day uh
you're flying
from 10 stories up you're going 1750
feet um you're traveling about 35 miles
an hour uh you're flying superhero style
so you literally feel like you're a
superhero i love it superheroes come on
down to celebrate slotzilla we have been
here for eight years and wednesday is
the big day so celebrating all week long
come on down fremont street tourists
locals everybody katy perry yes yes
fantastic all right we'll send it back
to you guys gotta get katie